You are studying tourism
or do you wish to work in this sector?
Here are the 5 jobs that pay for the
better in the tourism sector.
So, in 5th place,
we will find
the job of travel agent
with 1 average gross salary ofdeux-mille-cinq-cents
euros per month.
So,
this is the person who will advise his customers
by offering him stays adapted to his needs
and its expectations.
To access this profession,
you need 1 BTS in tourism or 1 BTS MCA.
In 4th place,
we have returned to the profession of chef
receptionist with 1 famous
ottoyen of €3,000 per month as well.
Its role will be to welcome customers
but also to manage
the filling of the hotel and to coordinate
the activity of all receptionists.
To access this profession,
it takes 1 BTS in hotels
or 1 license in hotel and catering.
In 3rd place,
we will find the profession of office director
tourism with 1 CR R gross
average of €4,000 per month.
So, his role,
it will be to centralize all the
tourist offers that there are
in fact in his life,
therefore on its territory,
but also to develop services for
attract many different audiences.
So,
to become the director of a tourist office,
it takes either 1 BTS
tourism and 1 pro license
tourism or land development
and you could access it
after 5 years of minimum experience,
or directly to my sister in European studies.
And international,
in 5th place,
we find the profession of tourist product manager
with 1 average gross CR ofsix-mille-cinq-cents euros.
It is in fact
the person who will prepare tailor-made stays
while respecting 1 specific specifications.
So, to access this job,
you need 1 baccalaureate plus 5 in marketing and sales
or in trade with 1 tourism option.
And finally,
the profession that pays the most,
is that of business analyst
in large hotel chains.
So that's 1 average gross salary of €7,000 per month.
This is the person who will
study the market and who will control the
financial mechanism
and hotel marketing.
So it requires 1 bac plus 5 in finance.
As we remind you,
these are average gross salaries,
so it's normal to have higher salaries
or lower
to society.
Wages will also depend on where you
work,
i.e. the company,
but also the city.
It will also depend on
your number of years of experience.
And if you want more videos in the same genre,
feel free to like and subscribe.